hello and welcome to this Wadi video
mope playing across shock so what are
you doing against my English opening mr.
Ross shock okay that's rare that's
really rare usually they play Bishop to
be 70 k is the night if five decent here
you should a six I will take c6 right
okay so he just allows me to recapture
which should be pretty nice for white
feeling catering so that that's very
debatable if a fianchetto is good for
black here because sorry because them
dark squares are critical on the
queenside and Black now has put them
yeah put his bishop on g7 I might even
get in d4 ID for you right how does he
prevent that don't see how
that's not a good opening result for
black c5 this d5 and e5 isn't playable
either okay
yeah so he tries to play the move that I
thought is not playable okay yeah I
understand he wants to he wants to
somehow break out but it shouldn't it
shouldn't be good so I can play a form
and just protect that I don't think
there's a big issue with this idea even
though is six um definitely on what the
worst worth considering as well thing is
I'm controlling you three so this night
isn't really doing all that much Bishop
a six maybe as an idea for him to take
you twice and then go into into this hmm
that's true if he takes a couple of
times this bishop and sorry this
couldn't be six but this I can answer
with bishop deform okay i hope the eight
makes some sense in this regard so um
what's going on here if i go age 3 is
going to do what exactly take a couple
of times check on b6 king edge one yeah
this is this is possible this is some
way to just protect all of that
I could play this more just
prophylactically
he takes a couple of times then Queen B
6 I can play move like mean to you too
yeah probably making some sense i mean
if i get h3 in here and he returns 93 or
something can also just play Bishop see
one in this position check check in g1
Queen B 6 that's kind of annoying if I
just get getting to it to go back and I
mean if there's no tactic striking then
I'm just winning this this position here
okay that is a tactic but how how much
of a problem is it if I get that one to
Bishop on c4 anyway that's not bad takes
takes Bishop c4
look the a drop due to its opposite
colored bishop sets of course not so
nice so where where is he going
potentially to differ I can go here
though Queen III there is rope the eight
might want to go here so i just want to
cover all the squares Bishop c-47 is the
thing that I would like to get in
threatening route d7 and rope the aid of
course I just capturing so I'm going six
years maybe it's a bit early with that
it's difficult here to figure out with
the limited time yeah i wonder if i
should play yeah okay let's do that if i
should allow an ending here in the first
place it's a little bit easier to
control this ending maybe not the best
choice objective limit I'm basically two
pawns up because the sea point I have
stopped very conveniently and have a
five King up to you for and then roll
this forward it's basically oh really
check
check time warning so this is fairly
well controlled
yeah but I'm almost threatening
checkmate down Queen f8 and made is a
threat so what 22 is just one check
check check that's no made oops he has
covered dad oh my god so so oh that's
that's not good I I just didn't see that
he covers it shoot check check check
mate ok wow that was a bad moment all of
a sudden I was thinking I'm meeting him
and he had GF all covered ok so let's
see what happened here I think he just
made a pretty bad decision in the
opening I think he a black should go
Bishop d7 I think this leads into some
kind of trouble already and now g6 this
is just not working very well together
white gets this big Center and he has no
real account to play this was already a
little bit desperate and objectively I
think white should win yet I'm not doing
anything stupid yeah the engine is on
plus two so wyd wins here with good play
um so I covered III ok the engine wants
to play just age three I didn't like it
so much what was what is the ends and
engines where you're playing this uh-huh
it just is this ok that's of course
possible yeah so this
the thing this is the point I didn't
consider to take with a pawn of course
it's stronger if black has to go back
something like g4 now or on c5 is
fantastic those pieces are absolute
absolutely terrible I never thought of
him still but I like this move it's a
good I think it's not it's a good
prophylactic move he took it Group D to
it should be four okay this is a very
good alternative pointed out by the
engine this is also not bad i think i
keep my advantage and here the bishop
will come to see for i was playing in a
very cautious way that would go
certainly more aggressive ways of doing
this but check I just wanted to keep
everything well coordinated yeah the
thing is he probably should take and try
to draw this but I'm not sure it might
be losing I have four against two i'm at
their mobile I can move those pawns
forward his three parts however are
completely blocked by my to this is
always an easy take on c4 so the gliders
in fantastic shape should probably win
ya know it was a bit of a bit of a
scramble now chan I absolutely did not
just not see that yeah g-force or its
mating basically a gvoice since meeting
he cannot do this just made okay yeah
this is also wasn't all that bad just
said I should go G for you and just win
check yeah I thought I'm just winning
easily here anyway and yeah yeah this
this was pretty stupid I was just not
seeing that I cannot Kochi for you
and now he has a draw with Queen g1
check and Bishop to c5 draw Jack gave it
he didn't didn't manage with this time
situation to to handle this tricky
tricky position okay well thanks for
watching